a message to Ethiopia's Prime Minister
RP Achmed from hundreds of mostly young
ethnic or more men outside the home of
the man they are calling their hero
throughout the day young men have been
coming to this neighborhood in Addis
Ababa they say they're gathering in
support to show solidarity to jawar
Mohamed the popular but polarizing
figure Mohamed owns the influential or
amia media network and has emerged as a
prominent activist since his return from
exile in the United States last year
some even credit him with galvanizing
support for the protests that brought
Prime Minister Abbey to power but their
relationship seems to have soured on
Tuesday Abby told parliament that people
with dual nationality who also own media
organizations should not stir up and
rest an apparent reference to Mohamed
who has dual US and Ethiopian
citizenship Mohammed calls that a threat
the prime minister in the parliament
publicly openly harshly threatened the
media myself which was I you you are
unexpected Mohamed has had official
police protection since last year
because of threats on his life late
Tuesday night he says security officials
arrived at his home and told his guards
to leave they refused Mohamed says it
was an assassination plot Isis and he
blames the prime minister's comments
that he carried some security officials
to independently act or whether he gave
some green light I'm not certain about
it yet however I don't believe this was
an isolated incident
Ethiopia's police commissioner and a
short-ass you denied Mohammed's account
saying his message that the police were
taking measures against him are false
neither the government nor the police
took any measure against him Wednesday's
protests began as news of the incident
spread through the state of or Emir and
at the end of our interview a further
twist I'm not sure for whatever for
or whether I run but I'm Caesar I'm
seriously considering direct and active
participation in the coming election and
even before that to help to ensure that
the transition that thousands sacrifice
ball for will not fall back elections
are scheduled to be held next May
Robyn Kriel al Jazeera Addis Ababa
[Applause]